[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: So
Sloane, you actually
did what we think is the
third talk at Google ever--
SLOANE CROSLEY: Oh, really?
SPEAKER 1: --about--
SLOANE CROSLEY:
You carbon-dated--
SPEAKER 1: We carbon-dated it.
It was 2018-- or, 2008.
So it was 11 years ago.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: What did you
think of going to California
and doing that first talk?
And what's changed?
What's different?
SLOANE CROSLEY: It was on
the Mountain View campus.
There were no-- there's a very
fancy clock in front of us.
There's a lot of--
that the tech is
more sophisticated.
But you'd think, even in 2008,
for Google, it would have been.
Feel like, oh, I just sat down
and started trashing my hosts.
No, but it was great,
actually, because I
came from a
corporate world where
I worked for Random House,
which is very much not too
far from what you
see of publishing
portrayals in the movies,
of sort of dusty old desks
and piles of petrified
rubber bands and manuscripts.
And to go to this place where it
just felt like the giant world
in "Super Mario Bros.,"
it was just incredible.
And there was so much free
water, of all-- not that--
but different kinds
of flavors of water.
But yeah, it was a
really nice audience.
And it was just like--
it was a long time ago.
But it was sunny.
SPEAKER 1: And you were still
working in corporate America
at that time?
SLOANE CROSLEY: I
was still working.
Yeah, maybe that's why I
was over-impressed by the--
that that's what I noticed,
more than the experience
of the reading, was sort
of all the different sort
of trappings were so much
more trapping-y than at Random
House.
SPEAKER 1: Fair enough.
We do have good trappings.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yes, you do.
SPEAKER 1: When you
started, did you--
you've done a lot of journalism.
Did you intend to become a
memoir and short-story writer?
Was that always
sort of where you
thought your roots really lie?
You've obviously done novels.
But you keep coming
back to this format.
SLOANE CROSLEY: I think
when I started my--
and I always wanted
to write fiction.
And then I sort of--
I often say that I fell
backwards into non-fiction,
which I should really stop
saying, because it sounds
very like, oh, this old thing?
It requires effort.
But it is a format I sort
of gravitate towards,
because it's close to
how I see the world.
I think heavily in analogies.
But I don't think
of it as a memoir.
It's not really--
I think of them as sort
of humor pieces or essays,
and not really
stories about myself,
even though they of course are.
SPEAKER 1: And what's it
like now, a year later?
The book's been out for a year.
What's it like
promoting the paperback
as opposed to the
hardcover, and having
lived with it for a year?
What's it like the second--
SLOANE CROSLEY: Lightweight?
SPEAKER 1: What's it like
the second time around?
SLOANE CROSLEY: It
is a little-- yeah,
I guess are you driving-- is
it like, play "Free Bird"?
Like you're sort of sick of it.
No, it's actually
great because the thing
is, in between, I have been
working on other things.
I do a little bit of
journalism, travel writing,
as well as a novel
I'm working on now.
So it's actually great to
remember that I can do this.
This can be done.
It can be bound and sold.
And it will happen
again, because no matter
how successful you get, I think
part of the health of that
is forgetting that anyone
would want to read something
and having to prove
yourself again.
So it is a nice little almost
lilypad to land on and think,
oh, that's right.
I did do this.
SPEAKER 1: I remember
these stories!
So I really love
female humorists.
And we just talked
about the fact
that you inject a lot of
humor into these essays.
And a lot of the books that
you see sort of on shelves that
are female-humor-driven
are the Tina Feys and Amy
Poehlers of the world, people
who are entertainers first.
What's it like approaching
it as a writer first?
And then, would you
ever think to say, well,
I'm actually going to
dive into their world
and do a little bit more
entertainment because--
SLOANE CROSLEY: I mean, I
try to entertain the people.
But yeah, I know
what you're saying.
I mean, I think it's almost not
really an artistic distinction
to me, but a marketing
distinction, where they have
a platform or whatever
it is ahead of time,
that people are going
to buy their books.
And the people
you mentioned also
happen to be fantastic writers.
But there are other people
who aren't as strong.
But it seems to be the
sort of trendy thing,
to whip up a book of essays.
And to that, I would just say
it's harder than it looks.
And similarly, I'm sure
being an entertainer,
or being a stand-up comedian,
is a lot harder than it looks,
or maybe exactly as
hard as it looks.
It looks hard.
But I feel like I
don't really feel
compelled to sort of dip my
toe into that world that much.
And I'm very happy
with where I come from,
which is a tradition that's
sort of more influenced
by Nora Ephron, Joseph
Mitchell, Dorothy
Parker, that kind of thing.
SPEAKER 1: That's awesome.
So who else is an
influence to you?
And what else are you sort
of reading these days?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Oh,
well, I just finished--
I always read these
dark, terrible things.
And it's funny.
If you ask David Sedaris,
he'll say the same thing.
He's always reading about
the Holocaust and taxidermy.
It's very weird.
Not together.
Oh my god.
That's a horrible joke.
But I guess what
I'm saying is I just
finished reading
"Giving Up the Ghost,"
which is a memoir by Hilary
Mantel, who wrote "Wolf Hall."
And it's fantastic
but very dark.
And I tend to read
that kind of stuff.
But in terms of who
I look to, often
it will be short-story writers.
I think that we have this
concept that obviously,
for narrative nonfiction,
we want to keep it pure,
and you want to tell the truth.
And of course that is true.
But the techniques you
use to tell these stories
are not so far off from
fiction techniques.
You know, there's
only so many ways
to say she sat in
the chair, right?
That's going to look the
same whether you're making it
up or telling the truth.
And so I do tend
to look towards--
I love-- Lorrie Moore is a
favorite, an idol of mine.
And then I don't know.
I mean, all of them?
SPEAKER 1: All of them.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Is "all
of them" a good answer?
OK, go ahead.
SPEAKER 1: Lorrie
Moore is a good answer.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Oh, good.
SPEAKER 1: So we'll
let that-- how
do you think you've
changed, your writing's
changed, since the first
two collections of stories?
What's evolved for you?
SLOANE CROSLEY:
Yeah, it's funny.
I hope that there's
been an evolution.
But in a way, it's almost--
I'm not really in a
position to see it.
It's almost not mine to
answer, in a weird way,
because it's the same
thing as you get a haircut,
and someone hasn't seen you
in a while, and you're like,
I guess?
Yeah, I guess this is-- or I
guess I have gained or lost
weight, or I'm taller.
I'm not taller, but--
that would be weird.
But so I don't see it,
these sort of giant
shifts, the way it might
look from the outside.
But I will say it's probably a
similar tone that I've always
had, just probably focused on
slightly more complex topics,
just to keep myself interested.
SPEAKER 1: Fair enough.
You have to keep yourself
interested, right?
SLOANE CROSLEY: You
[? can ?] entertain yourself.
No, it's true.
I feel like I will sometimes
pull out a random page.
And the worst thing you
can do as a writer--
this is a horrible tip, and
it's really masochistic.
But I pull out a page of a
manuscript, or a chapter.
And I imagine the
smartest person
I know who doesn't
like me reading it.
And if I could imagine that
person laughing or appreciating
it anyway, then I'm
like, OK, it's good.
SPEAKER 1: That's
a good technique.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yeah, it's awful
in the moment to imagine that.
SPEAKER 1: Do you know these
people who don't like you?
SLOANE CROSLEY: I
mean, I can guess.
We live in the world, you know?
I don't know.
SPEAKER 1: I can't imagine that
many people who don't like you.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Aw, thanks, Mom.
SPEAKER 1: How do
you determine--
I mean, I'm sure part of it is,
with these story collections,
it's a matter of time, right?
You're collecting
them over time.
How do you decide
what makes the cut?
And how do you decide
what the thread
is between these stories?
And what ends up on
the chopping block?
And do they get saved for later,
or do they get tossed away?
SLOANE CROSLEY:
They get repurposed.
It's like the Inuit.
Do I use every
part of the whale?
I can make a candle out
of this bone someday.
Yeah, I think-- most
essays-- there's
very few essays I've
ever written that were
written for one of these books.
And I work a little differently
than other essayists, who
tend to publish long-format
stuff in magazines,
and then collect them.
Most of the stuff I
publish on the regular
doesn't go into the books.
The stuff is written
for the books.
So therefore very
little is getting cut,
because it was always
meant to go where it goes.
The stuff that
gets cut is when I
feel that I'm just
complaining, which
is a real danger for a person.
SPEAKER 1: It is.
SLOANE CROSLEY: I once wrote a--
I mean, this is years
ago, but probably back
when I was fresh
from Mountain View.
I wrote an essay about
getting a parking ticket.
Oh my god, who cares?
Nobody, is the answer.
And if there's not
that universality,
if there's not some
sort of tentacle that's
reaching out to other
people's experience,
then it's sort of a dud.
So that stuff, generally
I'll save a funny line,
and then everything goes.
SPEAKER 1: We've all
gotten parking tickets.
SLOANE CROSLEY: I
mean, yeah, but nobody
cares about your
parking ticket either.
And I mean that in the
nicest way possible.
But no, seriously, unless
it was something about--
you can imagine it
being about some sort
of larger frustrating
experience, or something
about living in an urban center.
I'm just trying to
think of something
that would expand that at all
to it not just being like,
woe is me.
SPEAKER 1: What do you
like to complain about?
What are your pet peeves?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Everything.
SPEAKER 1: I know we just talked
about parades very briefly--
I also hate.
SLOANE CROSLEY: I hate parades.
SPEAKER 1: I hate parades.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Everyone-- yeah.
No one likes a parade.
But I feel like I always
describe it as sort of like,
I walk through the
world with one eye open
and one eye kind of cocked.
And if I go on vacation, like,
I was recently in Mexico City
and very adamant that
the people I was with--
I'm like, let's fling
ourselves down--
within reason.
I don't want to do
anything too dangerous.
But let's go as much
off the beaten path
as we can, and fling
ourselves down a dark alley.
And we did.
We found several dark alleys
that were good for flinging.
And then I just complained
the entire time.
So it's like basically,
I want to do this,
and then I want to be
miserable while I do it.
And that's where
I find my happy.
And that's really what
comes through in the books.
SPEAKER 1: And then you
go home and you write down
all the details.
SLOANE CROSLEY: And then I go
home and write down-- yeah,
and I think that is the tone
that is the most pervasive
in the books, is
that it's actually--
they're kind of upbeat, but
sort of snarky at the same time.
SPEAKER 1: What were you doing
in this alley in Mexico City?
SLOANE CROSLEY:
It's not important.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
So to that end, and to
talking about Mexico,
or you went and you
scaled a volcano.
You did all sorts of
things in this book.
So my question is, do you
look for these adventures,
knowing hey, this is going
to make a good story?
Do you just sort
of live your life?
How do these things--
I mean, you complained about a
neighbor who was really loud.
That wasn't something
you probably sought out.
But some of these adventures,
how does your mind work,
in terms of being
like, you have to be
collecting interesting stories?
Getting a parking ticket you
said did not make the cut,
so it can't just be things
that are super-mundane.
SLOANE CROSLEY: I'm not really
collecting them that much.
I don't go through
with this sort
of new kind of sensor on my head
because I do this for a living.
I think it would make me
a huge pain, honestly,
to be around, if I
just was doing things
for the sake of the piece.
I mean, it does
happen sometimes.
But usually, it's like
halfway through an experience
there'll be some sort of
moment that throws something
into a kind of sharp relief.
I mean, one of the first
essays I ever wrote--
and it's in the first book--
were I got locked out of
two different apartments
in the same day.
I was moving apartments,
and the same locksmith
came to bail me out eight
hours later, because it
was the same neighborhood.
And I had this doormat
that said "deja
vu" frontwards and backwards.
And you know, he's
filling out the slip.
And he pointed with
his pen and he goes,
that's a funny doormat.
And I just knew.
I was like, OK.
This has now congealed
in some kind of way.
So usually it happens like that.
But yes, I would
obviously rather not
have thrown up on
a glacier, which
is what happens in the book.
SPEAKER 1: Do you want to tell
everyone a little bit about--
SLOANE CROSLEY: It'd
be great if I didn't.
No, I'm kidding, I'm
kidding, I'm kidding.
Basically, a friend of mine--
I was going for a piece
to Quito, Ecuador.
And I had some extra time.
And I was like,
what should I do?
And I tried to
sort of crowdsource
through Facebook at the time.
And someone
recommended a museum.
Someone recommended a sort
of fun bar with good drinks.
And someone said, oh, you
should climb Cotopaxi.
And I could not be
bothered to Google it.
Pardon me.
And if I had, I definitely
wouldn't have gone.
It's huge.
It's not like K2,
but it's massive.
There's snow on top, a lot.
SPEAKER 1: Did you
learn a lesson?
Would you Google it
next time, if somebody
recommended something?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Is that--
[INAUDIBLE] the environment.
The lesson is google it.
SPEAKER 1: Google it!
We have tools for you.
SLOANE CROSLEY: We do.
We can make this
stop, although I
wouldn't have gotten the essay.
SPEAKER 1: You wouldn't
have gotten the essay.
So maybe not googling anything.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Don't google it.
SPEAKER 1: You'd be scared
to do anything that was--
and so when you have
these experiences, I mean,
I have a really bad memory.
So I would have to go home
and just kind of scribble
all the details.
What's your process?
Do you go, OK, I got
to run home right now,
and I have to write down as
much as I can possibly remember?
SLOANE CROSLEY: I mean,
it depends on the essay.
So for an essay like the
one we're talking about,
definitely I was sort of taking
notes as it was happening.
I mean, there's another
essay in this book that's
more of an interview
format, where I
interview my uncle, who was a--
there's no really good way
to say this-- a massive porn
star in the '70s.
SPEAKER 1: He's awesome.
SLOANE CROSLEY: He's great.
And he got into
pornography to find
a girlfriend,
which is what makes
him sort of sweet and special.
And so I interviewed
Uncle Johnny.
But I knew-- that's an example
where I obviously knew--
I wasn't interviewing
him for my health,
do you know what I mean?
So I obviously knew
it was for this.
But a lot of the
essays are years--
I mean, they're a
lifetime in the making,
right, because
you're trying to get
at some larger point that's been
brewing for a really long time.
And so I mean, the thing
to remember about them
is that they're not
being assigned to me.
So if you asked me to write
an essay about what I wore
yesterday, we'd be in trouble.
SPEAKER 1: Fair enough.
And from a journalistic
standpoint,
though, you do do a
lot of interviews.
Are those generally assigned?
Or at this point, do
you say, you know what?
I want to interview my uncle.
And maybe it's a
better format for that
than it is for my short story.
SLOANE CROSLEY: I mean,
I am lucky in that I
have-- oh, sorry.
I interrupted you.
SPEAKER 1: No, how do you
pick where it should live?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Well,
I'm lucky that I have--
it's like having
multiple homes, right?
It's like, does this
go in the summer house?
I don't know.
I mean, this could
be journalism.
This could be for a novel.
This could be for essays.
And I do a little
bit of screenwriting.
It could be for that.
But it's-- if you're
talking, like,
I just interviewed Laura
Dern for "Vanity Fair."
And it was wonderful.
But that was assigned to me.
I'm not deciding what goes on
the cover of "Vanity Fair."
But yeah--
SPEAKER 1: Not yet.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Not yet.
But it depends.
It's really not a
good answer, I guess.
It depends.
SPEAKER 1: No, that's a
great answer, because it is--
I think the point
is, you do live
in so many different worlds,
which is really cool,
and the fact that so
many of these things
can translate to
different places
and find different audiences.
SLOANE CROSLEY: It's great.
Well, it's also
because sometimes you
have to-- even within
the essays themselves.
So there's 16
essays in this book,
and they're structured slightly
different than the last two
books, in the fact
that there are
these palate cleanser,
tiny three-pagers
between the massive essays.
And they're there for a
reason, because if I tried
to make those stories
or those points larger,
it would bloat and
be a crappy essay.
SPEAKER 1: And I love
that, by the way,
because sometimes you do
need a palate cleanser.
Sometimes you-- because you
finish a chapter and you go,
oh, the next one's
only a half a page.
What a little--
SLOANE CROSLEY: I like to give
you a sense of accomplishment.
SPEAKER 1: So nice!
So I think varying the length is
something we really appreciate,
actually, especially
after you've
come off a really long one.
You need something.
SLOANE CROSLEY:
A soft landing.
SPEAKER 1: I think part of the
reason people love you so much
is that you're--
she's beloved-- is
that you have a talent
for balancing humor with some
more serious sorts of topics.
It's a hard thing to do.
I don't think people
really understand
how hard that is to do, because
being consistent in voice.
So do you ever go
to these essays
and think to
yourself, OK, maybe I
need to sort of balance
it one way or the other?
Or how does that sort of--
how do you make sure that
tone is reading consistently?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Oh, wow.
I was about to be like, that's
a good query, political, like
filibustering.
I'm like, well, it's
a good question.
I'm happy you asked it.
Next?
This is also going
to sound a little bit
like, oh, this old thing.
But the difficulty is in
making things less jokey.
SPEAKER 1: It is.
SLOANE CROSLEY:
The difficulty is
in actually not
imbuing something
with pathos, or
anything like that.
I think that most--
even though I'm not a stand-up
comedian, I am a comic writer,
you would call me, I guess.
And most people of
my ilk have some sort
of dark, desperate
sadness in their core.
SPEAKER 1: Do you have that?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Sure.
SPEAKER 1: That's
my next question.
SLOANE CROSLEY: A therapy
couch would be great.
I can just lie down.
But, and so I
think that the idea
of seeing the sort of
almost catastrophist version
of any scenario really
comes quite naturally to me.
I also do see things--
and the way I talk about it
is through a funny prism.
But if it's too jokey,
it can be a little
like symbol-bashing monkey.
And nobody likes--
we really do not
like people to try
too hard with humor.
It upsets people.
It does.
It's like, ugh, you're
trying too hard.
And I'm like, OK, well.
And so it becomes distracting
from the point of the essays.
So if I have to balance, it's
usually stripping jokes out.
SPEAKER 1: Interesting.
Do you ever go back and
read some of the essays,
and it helps you sort of
remember the experience?
Is it sort of almost--
can it be like a diary?
Or is that therapeutic
to go back and go, oh,
that was my experience.
I know two of the
essays you read
when you were here in 2008,
one was "Oregon Trail,"
and the other was finding
out that your mother had
been married before.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yeah,
really casually.
I was like 16 and I found an
extra ring in her jewelry box.
I was like, what's this?
SPEAKER 1: I had a
similar experience.
So again, talking to the
universality of these things.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Really?
Wow.
OK.
SPEAKER 1: But yes.
So does that-- do
you ever go back,
and it helps you sort of
remember them, because again,
maybe some of these
things are clearer
in the moment, or the
way that you put them?
Or do you go back and
go, well, maybe I've
changed my perspective?
What's that like, to have
this sort of collection?
SLOANE CROSLEY:
The answer is going
to-- it's not going to be good.
The answer is that it's the
reverse, because what happens
is you--
like anything, you don't
have to be a writer for this.
You get used to telling
a version of a story.
And if you've ever been
a part of a family meal,
I'm sure that things
get retold all the time.
And you bring in someone
new, and they're like, wow,
you really had a party that
time in high school, huh?
Your parents are really
still obsessed with that.
And it actually
doesn't always do this,
but it often will destroy
the original memory.
There's actually not a
lot of tangential stuff
I remember besides what
I wrote, after a while.
SPEAKER 1: Really?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yeah, sorry.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
We want to know!
SLOANE CROSLEY: But
it's not even a bummer.
It's just literally because--
but that's why I'm
careful with what I pick,
and not because about
exposure or what
I'm willing to sacrifice to
this or anything that noble.
It's just that--
I don't mind, because I feel
like when I wrote these essays,
I really took my time with them.
And I thought, OK,
I'm going to get--
I'm going to squeeze every
angle I can out of this one
experience.
So I don't think there's
a massive amount of stuff
I'm missing.
But every once in a
while I will forget--
like, there's a
lot of stuff that
happened in Ecuador
that I vaguely remember,
before and after throwing
up on the glacier.
SPEAKER 1: Were there
essays in the book
that took you a lot longer
to complete than others?
SLOANE CROSLEY:
Yeah, definitely.
Well, also, I mean, technically,
they're essays about childhood.
So if we want to start
the firing gun there,
they've taken me 30 years.
So I don't know how to--
but then there's one about--
there's a pretty big
one towards the end
about the pressure for
motherhood and fertility
and freezing your
eggs and should you
have a kid and women
judging other women and all
those goodies.
And that took a long time
to sort of percolate,
because I wanted to be--
usually it's a topic
that I feel has been heavily
tackled by other people,
and I also have
something to say.
But I don't want to
dwell on it, and I
want to get in and get out.
So the last essay in "How
Did You Get This Number?",
which is the second book, is
really one of the only books
I've ever written about
men and relationships
in this incredibly
concentrated way,
because I thought, I don't
write about this stuff.
I'm just going to
write the mother of all
this kind of thing and get out.
[MICROPHONE FEEDBACK]
Ooh, that was a little loud.
Sorry.
SPEAKER 1: Speaking of
the fertility essay,
what do you think of
egg freezing becoming
sort of part of the zeitgeist?
And did you feel like that
had been written about a lot,
and you wanted to bring
your unique perspective?
And then obviously having
a first-person perspective.
What do you think
about all of this
now as it becomes
more and more popular?
SLOANE CROSLEY: I mean, I
almost have no thoughts,
except for the fact
that it's a good idea
and you should do it
if you want to do it.
I wouldn't say it's
like a cure-all.
What happened to me--
I had no intention of--
freezing my eggs
became the locksmith
pointing with the pen in a
way, because all of the stuff
had been swirling around
in my head for a long time.
But I didn't think I was going
to write about it until I
got a tremendous amount of them
and broke the hospital record.
And that's lovely in some--
SPEAKER 1: Broke
the hospital record!
SLOANE CROSLEY: --in
that I am a fish.
But the issue is that I had
all these complications.
And then what became
interesting to me
is how self-conscious I
became, even now repeating it
outside of the page, that
it sounds like the worst,
most obnoxious
humblebrag for people who
are desperate to have
children, to say this, and go
through the expense and the
physical commitment to do it.
And that's when I really
thought about writing the essay,
because I was like,
this is insane.
It's arbitrary.
It's math.
I have no control over it.
And yet I feel extremely
judged for either what
I do with this information.
And so that was almost
like an anger essay,
to be like, all right,
everybody calm down.
SPEAKER 1: Well, it's a really
unique perspective, right,
because usually all--
SLOANE CROSLEY: And
it's also really--
medical stuff is so
fun to write about.
SPEAKER 1: Is it?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Oh my god,
it's so fun to talk about.
I don't know.
I'm probably-- if
we were friends,
I'd come home and be
like, look at this thing.
What do you think it is?
And I just find that
stuff really interesting.
I find interactions with
doctors very interesting,
because they can be so
flat, because they see--
if you go to a
specialist especially.
There's an essay where
I talk about having
this weird inner ear disease.
And this doctor is
so unimpressed by how
I'm spinning and falling
down and all this stuff.
And I think, well, of
course he's unimpressed.
The last person who
came in probably
had their nose in their pocket.
There's such a strange--
I just find them so
interesting to write about.
I find all medical
stuff interesting.
SPEAKER 1: In some ways,
it's bittersweet when
you have an ailment because--
SLOANE CROSLEY:
Oh my god, then I
get to see some weird doctor
who has no social skills,
and I can fillet him or her.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: So
you're a New Yorker.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: So that's exciting.
So you talk a lot in the
book about your experience
as a New Yorker.
I think we've talked a little
bit about universality.
What is it like to try to
bring that into your books,
to always bring in how
you live, what living here
is like, and trying to
make that relatable?
How does that
process work for you?
SLOANE CROSLEY: I mean,
maybe this is like--
maybe I'm so far gone in the
sort of New Yorker solipsism
thing, but I just
don't feel like--
I mean, that is like
the one effortless thing
about all this, because
we live in a microcosm
of the entire planet.
So there's also so much stuff.
So it's that on one side, and
the fact that it's not like--
I feel like it would
be less relatable
if I was in some sort of
really homogeneous city.
But then the other side of that
is that I just feel like we
tend to flatter ourselves
into thinking that there's--
you know, the "only in New
York kids" kind of thing.
That's not true.
People have incredibly
awkward interactions
with their boss in Minneapolis.
They hate their
neighbors in Kansas City.
SPEAKER 1: Not great.
SLOANE CROSLEY: We're not
that special snowflakes.
You know, it's just
that there's a flurry.
It's just that we're on
top of each other so much.
And so I'm not saying
there's not something
very special to New York.
It obviously permeates
the entire collection.
But it's so funny.
I never think of myself as
a New York writer, the way--
let's say, I don't know, Joseph
Mitchell was a New York writer.
SPEAKER 1: Sure.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Well, we're glad
you're in the neighborhood.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Thanks.
I am.
I live very close to here.
SPEAKER 1: So another
chapter in the book,
you were a guest star on
"Gossip Girl," which I watched.
You say you weren't
their first choice.
SLOANE CROSLEY: No.
SPEAKER 1: Do you know who
was their first choice?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yes.
Would you like to know?
SPEAKER 1: You
guys want to know?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yeah,
there's this essay
where I just quit my job.
I'm just setting
up a little bit.
And they basically had
a-- they needed an author
at a book party, at some
sort of fancy book party.
And their first choice
was Fran Lebowitz.
And she was like,
I'm not doing this.
And I took it.
SPEAKER 1: But you--
SLOANE CROSLEY: Oh, I had
no hesitation whatsoever.
SPEAKER 1: Were you
a fan of the show?
Did you watch it?
SLOANE CROSLEY:
Not even, really.
I just thought it
would be so fun.
SPEAKER 1: And was it so fun?
SLOANE CROSLEY: It was so fun.
Yeah, it was really fun.
It was also just a-- but it
was a strange-- but again,
that's a good example, though,
of something that would be just
a cocktail party story--
hey, this thing I did once.
That's a pretty good one, right?
SPEAKER 1: Absolutely.
SLOANE CROSLEY: If it weren't
for the fact that I had just
quit my job in publishing
to write full-time,
and I was playing a
writer on the show.
And everybody
treated me, frankly,
like I was Fran Lebowitz.
And it was so strange,
because I wasn't comfortable--
I think the first people I told
who said, oh, what do you do,
or what are you doing?
The first people I
said the words "I'm
a writer" to were probably Blake
Lively, because you're testing
it out on a stranger almost.
So that essay is
really about identity,
because I was also
playing myself.
So it becomes this bizarre
sort of Russian doll.
SPEAKER 1: Did you have a
little bit of imposter syndrome,
where--
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yes.
Well, also because I was--
the line as I'm
introduced in a way
that no one at any
book party would ever
be introduced, where
an agent comes over
to a group of the cast, and
it's Chuck and his parents.
And they say, this
is Sloane Crosley.
She's the best-selling author
of "I Was Told There'd Be Cake."
And I'm like, oh my god, how
do I dispose of my own body?
No one would ever say that.
And then I actually had to say
a grammatically incorrect thing
in response, which is "Of
which I am still in search of."
But I didn't want to correct
them because I was a guest.
So I said this thing.
And then I ran off.
And that was really the extent
of my acting experience.
SPEAKER 1: Do you wish you
would have corrected them now?
Do you wish you would've
been like, "you know what--"
SLOANE CROSLEY:
What's funny now,
now knowing a little more,
having worked a little more
in Hollywood, and knowing
actors and knowing
how fluid that is really, yeah,
I do wish I corrected them.
SPEAKER 1: What else are
you doing in Hollywood?
You mentioned you're doing
[INAUDIBLE] screenwriting?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Oh, no.
I have a couple pilots
that are in the works.
SPEAKER 1: That's exciting!
SLOANE CROSLEY: It is.
But it's also-- with a book,
you sign a contract and a book--
it's like, you can't be
a little bit pregnant.
Book comes out the other end.
But you can be a little
bit pregnant in Hollywood.
So Universal bought the
rights to "The Clasp,"
which is a novel I wrote, and I
wrote the screenplay for that.
And honestly, all this
stuff could lead nowhere.
But it's fun.
And frankly, it's lucrative.
So it's nice.
SPEAKER 1: That's always nice.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: And there
were rights for "I
Was Told There Would Be Cake"?
SLOANE CROSLEY:
Yeah, there were.
I mean, I don't think anything's
going to happen with it.
That book came out forever ago.
And now, it's also interesting.
There's so much-- you sort of
watch other things and other
art forms sort of--
I mean, not surpass
it in quality.
I stand by the book.
But in theme, right?
It's like, OK, we've heard
of this kind of thing now.
And so it's a very pleasant,
on to the next experience.
SPEAKER 1: So being at Google,
one of the essays that I
thought was most relevant--
maybe you can guess which one
it is--
was--
SLOANE CROSLEY: Oh, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: --was-- what
do you think it is?
SLOANE CROSLEY: I think
it's the domain name one.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah, that's right.
So you had your domain
name stolen on--
I mean, the web can
be a very dark place.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: This is not Google's
fault or anything involved.
We're making the
world a better place.
SLOANE CROSLEY: No.
This in no way reflects--
SPEAKER 1: But you went-- you
had your domain name basically
held hostage.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: And you decided
to go meet this person--
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: --and to hunt him
down and to confront him.
SLOANE CROSLEY: It was
my favorite dark alley.
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
Well, apparently you
like dark alleys.
You just told us
about Mexico too.
What did you learn
from that experience?
Do you think the
laws should change?
What ended up happening?
This seems like such
a bad thing that's
happening to so many people.
How do we make this better?
SLOANE CROSLEY:
There's almost no way.
SPEAKER 1: There's no way.
SLOANE CROSLEY:
Because what happens
is, if you let your
domain name expire,
which sort of happened to me--
well, this is embarrassing.
OK, so what happened was
that I gave GoDaddy--
so let's start there.
OK.
They were my host, or my
registrar, or whatever.
And I mean, I started my
website in 2007, right?
And so in 2007, my backup
to my backup email address--
so maybe this isn't
totally horrible--
was a Hotmail account.
It was already on its way
to graveyard status then.
And then what happened was,
when my domain name was going
to expire, which
I didn't realize,
GoDaddy kept sort of knocking
on the door of this abandoned
house and saying
it's going to expire.
We're warning you.
But it didn't matter to me.
I didn't live there.
And so they're sending all
these emails to Hotmail.
I don't get them.
All of a sudden, one day,
my email stops working.
And that's the other thing.
My email's connected to it,
which is why this happened.
So basically, it turns
out that someone has
bought, in the aftermarket--
which is like purgatory,
it's like the afterlife.
In the aftermarket, someone has
bought, at auction, my website,
and has this algorithm that
to me seems kind of nasty,
because he's not searching for
traffic, which makes sense,
but he's also searching for
the duration of ownership.
So I look like
what I am, which is
someone who's lost the family
heirloom and wants it back,
right?
So this guy does
this for a living.
His name is Wesley Perkins.
I offered to change his name.
He didn't want me to,
because he had a bit of a--
SPEAKER 1: Really?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Oh yeah.
I think he likes the attention.
And so I--
SPEAKER 1: Until
they change the laws,
and then he's going
to be like, the next--
SLOANE CROSLEY: And so a
magazine actually sent me,
and I flew over.
I was like, I want--
I took a screenshot when
he owned my information.
I wrote him-- after I paid him
a bunch of money to get it back.
And I wrote him and
I said, you know,
you might remember me from such
instances as five seconds ago
when I paid you
a bunch of money.
And I wanted to talk to him,
to figure out why he does this.
And it was really interesting.
It was a really
long conversation
we had about morality,
and it ended up
being a really interesting
essay to write,
and one I definitely took notes
on while it was happening.
SPEAKER 1: Awesome.
Can you tell us a little
bit about the cover?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yeah, the
covers always are sort of tonal.
I really find--
I think there's something
really graceful and beautiful
and a little sad but also a
little funny about that bird,
because I'm not
sure if it's dead.
It's probably dead.
And it sort of
dovetails, if you'll
pardon the pun, with the title.
And so yeah, that's really it.
I mean, it's the same thing.
And they're all like that.
They're all a little weird.
You know, I mean,
"I Was Told There'd
Be Cake" has a dirty
floral mattress on it.
There's no cake on the cover.
SPEAKER 1: Which is
what you asked for.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Kind of.
SPEAKER 1: You were like, I
want a dirty floral mattress.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yeah, I actually
did ask them-- it's funny.
I am very happy with that cover.
It's now become really
sort of connected
to the title in a really great
way, because the book did well.
But I remember asking them
at the time, I'm like,
can we mess it up, like,
put some stains on it?
I wanted it worse.
SPEAKER 1: Because I think it's
hard, because these essays--
you know, I mean, "The Clasp,"
it's very clear what the clasp
[INAUDIBLE]
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yeah, that
one's more obvious, because--
SPEAKER 1: But when you
have this essay collection,
you're first of all
trying to title your essay
collection, right,
and then figure out
what visually represents it.
And the title here too,
how did you sort of--
SLOANE CROSLEY: "Look Alive
Out There" is-- again,
because I always try to avoid--
in fact, I have successfully
avoided titling any of them
one of the essays in the book.
I just always think with
short stories and essays,
it puts a strange amount of
pressure on that one piece.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
SLOANE CROSLEY: So yeah,
there is a piece in the book
that I think is the best piece.
SPEAKER 1: There is?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Are you going to tell
us which one you think it is?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yeah,
it's "Outside Voices."
SPEAKER 1: "Outside Voices."
SLOANE CROSLEY: It's
about my neighbors.
I go crazy.
That's the one I like the best.
Not like cute.
Oh, that's cute!
But really like illegal crazy.
Please buy the book.
SPEAKER 1: OK, question.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Next!
SPEAKER 1: Please.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yes, please.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
First of all, thanks for taking
the time to come visit us.
My question is, I
was wondering what
is kind of your writing process,
especially when you're working
through cases where the
essay is not coming out
the way you expect or planned?
How do you work
through that phase?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Well,
thank you for thanking me.
You're welcome.
Thank you guys for having me.
I think that I do skip around a
little bit if I'm really stuck.
I try not to do that in general.
I'm not good at--
I think for fiction more,
maybe, I'll write like,
OK, this chapter isn't working.
I'm going to move on
and start this other one
and go back and fix it.
But essays are more
one train of thought.
I mean, generally
what I do is try
to go in another door
for the same topic.
I just feel like
I try to rewrite
the beginning a little bit.
And then if that doesn't
work, I take a walk or a nap.
I eat cheese.
I mean, until you
become unstuck.
I mean, and if it's that
stuck, then again, it's
almost like the parking
ticket conversation.
If it's that stuck--
there was an essay that
was supposed to go
into this book about I
jumped off a cliff in Australia.
I'm not really like that.
I don't know why--
but-- there was water.
But I-- yes.
Very important.
But it just didn't-- it wasn't--
it just didn't seem
that special to me.
It just didn't seem that
funny or entertaining.
I don't know.
It's really hard to
actually tell you
what the litmus test is.
But very few times do I just
whole-stop abandon something.
It usually gets repurposed.
But I'm not above doing that.
But mostly I rewrite
the beginning.
AUDIENCE: My question is--
well, YouTube being
what it is today,
the way people are entertained
has changed a lot--
podcasts, YouTube videos.
Has your process
changed on evaluating
the measurement of
how people are going
to be entertained by your work?
Has that changed over maybe
the last five, 10 years?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Wow.
Yeah, am I sort of factoring
in people's attention spans?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, kind of.
SLOANE CROSLEY: I try not to.
I'm sure I am, though.
I'm sure I am, because
I tweet, tweeted, twit.
And I've even made--
for the novel, I made
a book trailer with--
I mean, it was a full trailer.
Like, Amanda Seyfried was in it.
It was not-- and her dog.
And it had a whole premise,
which is that the dog has read
the book and she hasn't.
And she's a bad
book club member.
I don't know.
It was weird.
But a friend of mine who
directed it was like,
no, we have to make it
shorter, shorter, shorter.
I'm like, it's a
minute and a half.
And I feel like I sort of
straddle, either consciously
or even generationally,
some sort of line
where I understand
your question.
I know that it's a problem,
or that it's just different,
how people digest things.
But I also tend to be
super-old-fashioned
in my humor.
I write about topics like--
yes, like egg freezing
and I don't know, drugs.
But I tend to
approach it from a--
I have an older
fan base sometimes.
So I tend to try to
avoid putting things
into sound bites,
as is demonstrated
by the length of my
answer to your question.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Coming
from publishing,
I have two questions.
You can pick and choose maybe.
But first, do you feel like
you have a catbird seat of what
you need to have happen in order
for your book to be successful?
And also, just like, help,
how do we fix publishing?
Do you have ideas for
this dying industry
that is so important
for the world right now?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Well, it's not--
OK, so I do have a
catbird seat, but not when
it comes to the most
important part, which
is creating the book,
writing the book,
doing anything that could
be construed as art.
That seat's dangerous to have
anyway, even if I had it.
You don't want to
think about if this
will be successful
for a certain reason.
Or maybe you do.
I don't know.
I mean, it depends.
If you're trying to
follow some formula--
you know, it's funny.
I did an interview
with "The Guardian"
I remember a few years ago.
It was more than
a few years ago.
It was like 10.
And they asked me if I
was trying to identify
a marketplace with essays.
And I said no.
If I was trying to
identify a marketplace,
I'd write about Abraham
Lincoln or vampires.
And this is before
the book came out.
And so I'm like, wow.
I really messed up.
It's the pull quote
from that piece too.
But your question about
how we fix publishing,
I don't think it's that broken,
any more than the record
industry is broken or any
other industry is broken.
I mean, there are
wonky things that
shouldn't work that do work.
It's like how bees
aren't supposed to fly.
They're not
genetically-- physically,
their bodies are too
big for their wings.
They shouldn't be able to fly.
But they do.
And similarly, for
some reason, it
makes sense to send an
author on a book tour.
But I mean, books,
independent bookstores
are doing extremely
well right now.
Online is sort of a
different problem.
But I don't know.
I mean, it's really hard.
I mean, when I first
worked in book publishing,
I had this rather sort of naive
maybe idea that I was like,
oh, it's so great, because
I know so many people who
are incredibly intelligent, but
they work in other industries,
and they don't read, and I'm
going to get them to read.
And then I realized
how hard it is
to get people who
do read to read.
It's impossible to just
get them to buy the books.
So I don't know really
what the answer is,
except for to
continue to support
the few literary breakout books
that happen that aren't just
crap, and just hope that
people think to themselves,
there's more where
that came from.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question.
When you're writing
nonfiction, to what extent
do you tell the
stripped-down, raw story,
or embellish it for the
aspect of the storytelling?
SLOANE CROSLEY: I mean, I
sort of lean towards hyperbole
and towards analogy.
So obviously the first essay
in this book, there is--
I'm waiting on a street
corner for a cab,
and there's a woman in a
wheelchair and a guy standing
next to her.
And of course, this cab
comes with the sliding doors.
And I'm like, OK, even though
I was here first, I'm like,
you guys obviously take it.
And they're like,
thanks so much.
And the guy leans down the
wheelchair and kisses the woman
and hops in the cab,
and then she wheels off.
And I'm like, holy shit.
Sorry.
And I said, I have
a line where I say,
obviously this is the worst
person to have ever lived.
Probably not.
I mean, number eight, maybe.
But I just feel like, I guess--
so in that sense, very much so.
It's my style, right?
But in terms of
telling the truth,
I'm really close
to the hole, which
is a golf term I don't own.
But I get as close
as I possibly can,
because I feel like I don't
know why people are doing this
otherwise.
And I'm not trying to--
I'm completely abstractly
shading a lot of people
right now.
But yeah, this is the
truth of what happened.
And it's only for
technical reasons
that things tend to get shifted.
So the essay I said I really
liked about my neighbors who
were these sort of hellions,
that's probably the biggest
lie in the book, because that
essay is in the past tense,
and I still live
in that apartment.
But they graduated.
And they did not go
to NYU, I don't think.
But the point is that
I do it because I
feel like I-- when
I have to, there
is embellishments in that way.
But otherwise, it's pretty
close to what happened.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Thanks.
SPEAKER 1: Any last questions?
I have a few.
Oh, we have one.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering,
if I understood right, you
said you're adapting "The Clasp"
for television and whatnot.
I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit
about the kind of screenwriting
and about adapting
your own work for
a different medium.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, so basically,
it's for film.
And it's weird because at
first, it's unpleasant,
because obviously these came
out as essays for a reason.
Like, I don't write poetry.
I don't write songs.
You wouldn't want to see them.
But so at first, it
felt kind of weird.
Like, haven't I
already done this?
And I'm not a great actress.
I'm like, I already
delivered it once.
I can't just do it
again, you know?
And then what happened was I got
to restructure and honestly fix
everything that I felt
was wrong in the novel.
So for that reason
only, I kind of
hope it gets made one
day, just because it's
like an apology to myself for
not fixing that to begin with.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: You
mentioned somewhere
that you want people, when
they're reading your book,
to feel like they'd found
their other old man Muppet.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: You know
what I'm talking about?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Still
my-- what are their names?
This is horrible that I
don't know their names.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, it's, um--
SLOANE CROSLEY: Something--
SPEAKER 1: Statler and Waldorf.
SLOANE CROSLEY: I
love this crowd.
Yeah.
Statler and Waldorf.
SPEAKER 1: Is that--
so that's how you--
what were you saying?
Tell us what you--
SLOANE CROSLEY: Well, that
"stuck in the middle with you"
feeling, right?
I mean, that's the thing, is you
want to read essays, especially
if they're personal or they're
narrative, and connect to them
and think not necessarily
that you want to curl up
with the author, but that you're
facing the same direction.
You've got the bar
seats, not the table,
where you're just sort of
facing the same direction,
and that feeling you
have with someone,
whether it's a friend,
boyfriend, girlfriend,
whatever, partner, where
you meet eyes across a table
when someone said something
ridiculous at a large dinner.
And you almost can't look at
them because you'll lose it.
And that's the goal
for the essays.
SPEAKER 1: So does that make--
so people who read
your book probably
feel like they're
already your friend.
They already-- you said before,
people know so much about you.
And it's an uneven
playing field.
SLOANE CROSLEY: It is an
uneven playing field, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: That is
part of your charm,
right, is that people
think, oh, we're friends!
I read all of her books.
I know all of these things.
SLOANE CROSLEY: It
does happen like that.
I will say, since we're
sort of wrapping up,
just that there is another
version of myself, which
is I was once on the subway.
I'll end with a New York story.
I have a prop.
This is so good.
I'm going to use it.
I was on the subway,
and this woman
was reading my second book.
And she was sitting
directly across from me.
And you know, not on a
e-reader, so I can actually
see what she's reading.
E-readers have spoiled half
the spying in New York,
and judging.
But she was doing this.
And she seemed totally
just really ensorcelled
by the language.
And I was like, this is so cool.
Like, do I say anything?
What do I do?
And she does one of these.
And she goes, [HEAVY SIGH].
Like, the check
of the binding to
see how much longer she
has to slog through it.
And I was like,
then I felt really
like, this is going to
be really awkward if she
recognizes me and wants
to talk to me about it.
SPEAKER 1: So you scurried away.
SLOANE CROSLEY: So
I scurried away.
It was that or trip her.
But I scurried away.
SPEAKER 1: And my last
question is, what's next?
I mean, you're very prolific.
You're doing a lot of things,
and it takes a lot of time,
obviously.
Probably your next
essay collection
we won't see for a
while, because you
have to build up these stories.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: Right?
SLOANE CROSLEY: True.
SPEAKER 1: So read this
one, and read it slowly.
But what's next?
What can we expect
to see from you?
SLOANE CROSLEY: Probably a
novel, if it ever gets done.
But honestly, at
the rate the novel
is going, maybe the essays.
A book.
It's not going to be, like, a
diorama that I come up with,
or a puppet show.
It'll definitely be a book.
SPEAKER 1: It'll be a book.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Oh, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: It's a book, guys.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Front to
back, bound, little price.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you so,
so much for being here.
Everyone--
SLOANE CROSLEY: Thank
you for having me,
and thank you for
your questions.
SPEAKER 1: Please go
out, buy, and read
"Look Alive Out There."
It's great.
And let's thank Sloane one
more time for being here.
SLOANE CROSLEY: Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
This was so nice.
[APPLAUSE]